us now with more senator lindsey graham
the great state of south carolina sir
how are you good to have you back
um you recently got back
well you recently got back from taiwan
i've got to imagine
that they are in a heightened state of
alert based on the obvious the
the fighter jets from china flying over
their airspace fairly regularly uh the
talk of reunification by president xi
that's not reunification that would be a
takeover of a sovereign country and uh
in light of the lackluster response of
biden and ukraine i'm not impressed uh
particularly
i would say that the odds are pretty
high that this is coming are we prepared
for that
well how ukraine ends really will
determine what happens in taiwan i
believe that i went to australia onto
taiwan and japan afghanistan looms large
everybody is doubting america's resolve
after afghanistan but the fight the
ukrainian people are giving to the
russians has inspired the taiwanese
they're about to change your
conscription laws to make people serve
longer to go to a civil defense force
america needs to up its game in asia if
you want to give china a great gift
destroy our economy by reducing carbon
here in america by 50 percent by 2030
and do nothing to china and india the
chinese in the indian economy would
flourish if we destroyed manufacturing
in america and had seven to eight dollar
a gallon gas for for the american
consumer because of this religion called
climate change but i i just got back
from asia there's doubt about america i
haven't seen this doubt since i've been
in congress and we need to remove that
doubt by giving more weapons to the
taiwanese showing up in australia as a
more reliable partner and japan's
expanding their defense footprint we
should encourage that so afghanistan
looms large and biden is a
there's a lot of doubt about america and
we need to remove that data if we can't
you know i always talk about oil gas and
coal being the lifeblood of the world's
economy now by abandoning the energy
independence policies that one of the
great achievements of the trump
administration maybe one of the the top
um because energy was so cheap and
abundant and
uh i would argue that the geopolitical
implications of abandoning those
policies are felt not only in ukraine
but it's going to be felt in china and
we almost see a realignment of of
alliances in the world you see that
vladimir putin and president xi and the
iranian muellers seem to be getting
closer uh that that is an axis of evil
that the world will have to reckon with
one day if that happens
well everybody's hedging their bets look
at india india is reluctant to take
russia on because they buy all their
weapons from russia so without american
leadership we're the glue that holds the
world together people in japan and
australia and taiwan are yearning for
ronald reagan-type leadership and the
one thing i would say to the republican
party everything you say about the
democrats is true in terms of their
policy but i'm begging president trump
and the republican party to come up with
an american first agenda that addresses
the border energy independence inflation
a strong national security it's not
enough to complain about the other side
we need to have a vision of how we would
change this country and restore order
and
make the economy stronger at home we
need a positive agenda it's not enough
to run these guys down and everything
right so i want to show what we would do
newt gingrich has
spoken to me and kevin mccarthy's coming
up next about what would be yeah
yeah as of now maybe the top 10 things
that republicans pledge
promise to the american people that they
would do something like a contract with
america i like the idea and i'm only
going to support candidates that support
america first save america make america
great again policies because they work
and they worked and they will work again
all the problems joe biden has senator
are preventable and fixable but we need
the right people in power to do it
so is that something that the senate
will also
go by will you sign a pledge if they if
if there's 10 items that you agree with
well nude news brilliant and kevin's
been a great leader and he's going to be
speaker but donald trump is the leader
of this party not kevin mccarthy not
lindsey graham
based on america's first agenda
yeah i'm hoping soon he will lay out a
positive agenda here's what i would do
at the border here's how i would secure
the border again remember me i'm the guy
that controlled the border here's what i
would do to deal with russia and china
here's what i do to rebuild the military
and here's what i would do to make us
energy independent and lower inflation
president trump has proven he knows how
to do these things he needs to remind
the american people of what we did in
the past and what we can do in the
future and it's about the future the
election is about the future and if this
is a policy debate we'll kick their ass
if it's a personality debate we might
lose
oh i'll take the guy with the mean tweet
so it was actually that the world uh
that yes that the hostile regime leaders
feared uh and whose policies led to
prosperity over the guy that doesn't
know uh that today's wednesday any day
kind of not not a hard choice
anyway lindsey graham thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else